[Musik] [Applaus] [Musik]
meine Damen und Herren liebe Studenten
herzlich willkommen im Hörsaal 1 der Rudolf
scharping-universität Hannover bis wir hier
exemplarisch sehen ist der deutsche Rentner
homo gerontosaurus und zwar das männliche
Exemplar natürlich erkennbar an dem korthut
ohne den könnten wir ihn von
den Weibchen nicht unterscheiden
so zwischen korthut und der Schädeldecke
existiert ein Feuchtbiotop aus schädelschweiß
und Schuppen indem der Herbst zahnlose seine
resttag konserviert durch die gärungshitze
unter der cordglocke ist der prägen immer
zwei Grad wärmer als es gut für ihn ist
in der Folge produziert der Kreise Faltenwurf
in der Rübe absurde Weltbilder primitive
Erklärungsmuster oder einfach nur dummes Zeug
die Oberbekleidung das sehen Sie hier besteht
aus einer sogenannten Windjacke in der
Farbe flüssiger pudelkot ja seine absolute
Lieblingsfarbe in der er möglichst viele wenn
nicht alle Kleidungsstücke erwirbt ein Reisebus
voller gleichfarbiger Rentner sieht deshalb von
außen aus wie ein Aquarium mit toten Karpfen
stell dir mal eins sagen Sportfreund hat
man nicht so große Fresse du wir von der
E60 Partei sind die meisten in diesem Land die
SPD und die CDU sind zu 90% bei uns und sogar
die frosch- hat geschlossen der Verband in der U60
Regiment ein und dann zieht euch warm an er Kapuze
denn wir regieren das Land ja spätestens
dann wandere ich aus viel Spaß
die deutsche laubkultur ne zum Beispiel mal
jetzt neben Vergleich zu dem Flüchtling seine
Kultur muss man mal gesagt werden ne da sind
ja hauptsächlich was in Deutschland ausmacht
da derjenige ganze november bis weit
in den Advent hinein am Laufen ist
da macht sich der Mann aus der
Wüste ja gar keinen Begriff von
heute hat für eine mordsmäßige Schweinerei ist
auf dem Bürgersteig oder aber Stellplatz von PKW
allen voller vergammelte Blätter
die Wüste die wirft kein Laub ab ne
wegen Bäume nicht da da kann der moselmann der
fein seinen pkw-parken wo immer er will kein
Problem sitzen auch keine Luft Ratten die in den
Jetter zu scheiße hat er wieder eine Viertelstunde
gespart oh mein Gott zu machen nach Mecklenburg
oder wo immer das ist ne blöde Schwein [Applaus]
selbst wenn wir zu denen seinen Glauben
übertreten das wird zeitmäßig gar nicht drin
sondern zwischen September und November der
alles mit Laub voll da kannst du nicht mal
fünf mal am Tag auf dem Knie rumrutschen außer
wenn du gleichzeitig mit dem Schälen besser dann
Unkraut aus den Pflaster rauskratze tätig ist
weiß nicht wie der Teil erlaubt ist in den in
seiner Religion nee aber für den Zweck gibt es
bei uns auch Herbizid wird alles totgespritzt
aber bleibt ja das Hauptproblem wenn die Kollegin
von der unten zu uns herkommen und im Oktober
mit dieser laubkultur konfrontiert werden da
fällt den aber die Sandalette auf den Knien
wer so hätten sich das nicht vorgestellt so viel
Laub und dann vielleicht hat Angela Merkel dann
für Sie wegmachen täte von wegen Freundchen ne das
sollten sie mal in die Goethe-Institute haben weil
die alle ne sollte das mal drauf pochen dass sie
den Wüstensöhnen immer verklickern komm mal her
Freunde so wie du dir das vorstellst die Germany
so ist das nicht ab September muss erlaubt werden
ja auch vom Container ja ja und vom Zelt ne das
ist die Kehrseite von der Wohlstandsgesellschaft
da muss Laub gefegt werden kann alles weg die
ganze Blätter auf deutsch gesagt muss mal gesagt
werden meine Meinung sagt ja sonst keine Ahnung
muss ich auch mal irgendwas sagen [Applaus]